at menos and i love it yeah love like
that I love the way how she knows what
she doesn't say I don't know why she's
in the car though you know thanks for
each other people events are the heels
they love ya you know she like just in
case you don't know what I'm talking
about theatre I know you know a moment
to tell me we're being open and honest
with each other nope alright well fine
then no yeah she's in the corner of the
room with the newspaper like you know
spider-man right on in a while yeah
someone uh seems like people need him
yeah perhaps you should get your ass out
yeah he was already really haunted by
the fact that like Gwen Stacy's dad was
dead and loving and you know he blames
himself for that that is up that is the
plot device that makes this a standalone
movie to like the way he keeps appearing
that's that's the one thing you need to
fill in that hole and there you go so I
did feel like a part 3 like leaving that
emotional term cuz likely you it's like
you feels like it's his fault why what
is dead and in some ways you might go
kind of is your fault a little bit you
know yeah you did all you could in it
and it wasn't quite enough it's like I
could see how that could be really
compelling trauma to watch him go
through that and you could see like
anger and come out and all this other
stuff l like we could have gotten a
really interesting side of Peter Parker
but if we had a part 3 where they took
the time for that I mean he could have
introduced venom and it would have been
cool I imagine they will though
especially because if they're gonna if
they're gonna introduce Mary Jane I I
don't know what they're gonna do I think
they would be very smart if they sort of
explore that whole life I'm kind of
responsible for my last girlfriend's
death I don't think I don't know if I'm
ready for that and then like end that
movie with them getting together yeah
yeah like I think there's still
territory to explore even though they
only wrap that story up in this one so
much as he goes back to being spider-man
as a way to I mean cuz he has a world
duty but also I imagine probably as a
way to distract himself this guy I
thought would steal the [ __ ] screen
every time he was on dane dehaan I loved
him in this film I really liked his
portrayal of Harry Osborn why it took me
a few minutes to get used to him because
of the way he speak and there's a lot of
looping in the
seen he has a very sort of late lay back
way of talking not stuff it doesn't seem
like it quite fits his face yeah so for
the first couple scenes I was like okay
kinda and then when they really let the
camera be with him for a while I was
like all right I like what you're up to
and I was very happy that that scene
played out differently then Peter Parker
Harry Osborn I prefer watching his
version over James Franco's weird sad
but charming well you know because he's
a slacker a [ __ ] but like I like what
Dane DeHaan does here and that's the
only thing that bums me out about the
way that story goes is because like wow
I really like this guy I wish I could
see a movie that devoted more time to
him yeah yeah its subtlety to it
especially when we first see him because
they just kind of hinted at being
tortured I did think that there was not
enough of an arc in his character to
like to get so upset like I understand
the reasons why but he kind of started
off at like an eight and then went to a
ten and then once he reached 10 you
can't really go higher than that so that
was my only issue with him I do however
prefer him to James Franco when he gets
to the breaking point we seem to have a
minor disagreement here Lexi and that's
okay you can have your opinion I have
mine doesn't mean we have to hate each
other he's like breaking into the jail
and he's like talking like that moment
where he's talking to max and he's like
st. like yes I need you and stuff that
was a really good [ __ ] scene well I I
felt more of his drive more than I did
feel max's that seemed really does give
them like yeah I can see why these two
dudes are about to work together I feel
like a lot of times when they when they
team up it's kind of like forced it's
like yeah we wouldn't know and i'll help
you but then i'm gonna stab you in the
back it was like no they really had a
common goal and it was like you know
more than most we both hate spider-man
when he and when he said to him I know
what it's like to be left behind I know
what it's like to be forgotten max still
remembers that past that he has no one
noticing him no one's seen him that's
like a bond other than the whole were
mad at spider-man the one thing I wish
there had been more explanation for was
like the one time we see Norman Osborn
Harry I got a bunch of [ __ ] to tell you
don't mind my crazy ass monster and
Oh see I got the sense that he already
knew what like what his dad was dying up
you know what I like is how they had her
teasing Jay jonah Jameson I know like
they don't haven't shown him he wasn't
at all in the first one and then you
tease his personality in this one but I
was hoping we could see like at least a
cameo of whoever it is oh he was among
the email who was like no wrong yeah I
think they should just get JK Simmons
back I really don't think that would be
great yeah really good I was hoping
that's what they would do with this
movie is that just show him is like oh
my god we brought that is nothing i will
say about this movie it's a testament to
the fact that the script was very good
that all of these name actors came in
and did parts and a lot of them had
smaller parts when he and Harry
reconnected that was a really strong
seen especially out by the water and
stuff the only problem I had with it was
that they kept saying it's complicated
and it was just like are you making the
social network reference no people says
that no I know beautiful I know I know
but it was just like they kept saying it
so it was just kind of a media are they
part of a scene universe is that what
they're doing it didn't know no that's
why Mark Zuckerberg is gonna be a
billionaire I liked the way they
reconnected and like they made fun of
each other cuz let's help tell boiler
that's true well like this idea sure I
love it when they don't [ __ ] is
your hair's still curly is your cousin
real they still have hair on it what
maybe yeah do I throw some rocks right
now yes yes donor to yeah oh yeah that
part was so adorable he was so cute
they're my favorite moment was when he
was in the bed we have no chimney whoa
Thank rack we have so much it's a
standalone movie and I love being able
to you know see a sequel and see if it's
a standalone or not because I was able
to follow everything there wasn't any
cars I was just kind of like um I want
there to be a recurring motif in these
movies were every film he just finds
another voicemail that Uncle Ben
Laughlin every now and stacy is
laughs him something the next minute
yeah well then really where you're going
Lynette [ __ ] that was gonna be another
thing from beyond the grave yeah I'll be
good if that's the next woman say like
resurrect her she's Asami oh dude now
Hollywood here comes a real rejects is
that who gwen stacy is supposed to be
that's exactly who she's supposed to be
all right then I had a problem is it no
I don't know idea I don't Harry is
obviously tortured he's supposed to be I
keep using that word but I can't think
of a better one covered in him yeah look
at your hair recovery I they're covering
ninety percent of my body except for my
eyes what Harry Osborn oh I also really
like that Aunt May was not so old in
this one yeah that's a plus always not
like that lead I felt like I picked it
apart a lot but I really really enjoyed
it like I'm recommending it like it
might not sound like it but a lot of
people who are recommending it are also
saying like they're breaking up the
flaws but it kind of doing just what I'm
doing right now like I'm ringing up all
these flaws but I'm like me to know at
the end of the day it's a pretty good
movie actually it's still funny l in the
right moments it's still a heartfelt a
lot of the time the romance is good the
action is spectacular I noticed when he
saved max a lot of other [ __ ] people
died in order for him to say max did he
completely forget about the fact that
Rhino just smashed into all these cars
and they all flipped over and [ __ ] a lot
of people died because he wanted to play
around and taught know for a while I
like Phillip Phillip but that one
montage where they had his song over and
I was like something about Peter just
doesn't seem like he listens to this
kind of music yeah I thought it worked
for the scene but I didn't buy that he
would be listening that is like is that
why you work the headphones out what you
guys expect is gonna be good at from it
yeah you know it's gonna be good so this
is a spoiler talk so just because this
is the minden yeah yeah just because
we're gonna learn nitpicky dozen doesn't
mean it's not word well you know what
over on that note why don't we give some
reasons to see it I would say first
reason to see it Andrew Garfield Andrew
Garfield yeah Andrew Garfield it's Peter
Parker he's
anchor of this movie to me yeah he's
pretty [ __ ] sweet loved him a lot you
want to see him cry you can get a lot of
that the Peter Parker crowded good
character driven dialogue now be number
two over to say writing then to make it
more summarize I don't think the writing
is always perfect but what is good is
definitely good i would say reasons
three through eight or rhino yeah he's
probably using the morning sores at the
top yeah I mean he has the majority of
screen time it's really just a character
Danny about it yeah wouldn't he's on
there it's like you forget that's my
rant even in this movie man you're just
so pulling no reason to see number three
I almost feel lob cited in saying this
but I just I love Sally Field in this
and she stands out to me so I don't know
is that fair yeah sure I just think
she's good I don't really have an order
for these i would say part for a reason
to see number four would have to be uh
dane dehaan DeHaan he is Dane Cook Peter
Peter I'm dying of a disease yeah I've
got chemicals in my body I knew eating
up my cells I'm gonna die what's number
five lexi number five is love story good
romance romance it's real and its raw
and it's like very identifiable reason
to see number six you know I think when
when he's on Jamie Foxx is good when it
works at work did he brought it back to
those in living color days man I don't
have to say a reason to see number seven
action and visual effect ya can't deny
that they're pretty [ __ ] sweet even
though you walk out not really thinking
about it because that's not the real
star of this movie the Stardust movies
the drama yeah yeah which I appreciate I
appreciate I appreciate that too I just
thought if he did you have another
reason Emma Stone like oh yeah yeah yeah
I'm a stone she was funny she was cute
she does what she does best yeah yeah in
this movie reminding me it was like
watching easy a meets the social network
don't know why I felt that I was like
watching rescue me so much in earnest
intermittently felt like risky i would
say i would say directing because he
didn't write the script and that's a lot
too
go ahead for the most part I thought he
did a pretty good job the fact that this
doesn't collapse yeah exactly the fact
that I was like I was able to follow it
I bought it it's good Nina I had a good
time you know it's I get some of the
economical decisions that probably got
made but the fact that if it ever tried
started to lose me at one me back so
many times yeah I'll say art direction
if you look in each scene like it you're
not ever hit over the head with like
this is who where this character lives
or where they hang out or like
especially in the roosevelt area like
that was very much locked in time and
stuff but it didn't be like just so you
know this is not from right now you know
was it was very accurately done very
subtly done just for some reasons not to
sing yeah i mean not nothing major but
yeah it's a little uneven not even it's
a little what's the word all over the
place Oh sometimes there's too much to
sometimes it tries old sometimes its
reach out out out strips it's wease
covered most of this review talking
about what might outwards its grasp the
amount of things they're trying to do so
not everything gets the full time you
wish it could I guess I don't know how
to describe that in like two words but
yeah I honestly think this is gonna be
the movie that I wake up to tomorrow and
go I wish I said this instead because I
love this movie as I think about it more
alright guys say it's checking out a
review for spices over by the way like
why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and tell us what other
ways do you think wednesday see coulda
died and once you're done with that one
shot click over click on this button so
you can see more episodes of our reasons
to see operation last but not least if
you want to get updated every time one
of our videos or reviews or whatever is
out subscribe click on Lexie to
subscribe people you you dupe doses dude
andrew garfield's so cool he's one of
those people when I walk out of a movie
I go I want to be this guy I've done
movie wanting to make out with that guy
so I know exactly how you I walked out
with a little bit of both of those
things yeah this movie is brought to you
by the two most confusing writers in all
of Hollywood because these are two toes
I wrote so many transmitters movies but
also wrote the Star Trek movies but then
also wrote this I'm like I guess you
could write a good script when you feel
like it you know is weird the mid
credits of spider-man 2 with the x-men
days of future past I was like I don't
know how you felt I felt like like
Ralphie and a Christmas tree I was like
really a commercial you teased us with
the next spider-man it was vague but you
teased us with something new in that one
you just showed us a trailer for [ __ ]
exit yeah you just showed us a
one-minute clip of the movie that is
what you've done I actually like I
actually felt kind of upset I was like
really this doesn't tie in to anything
we just saw it's not related at all it's
not like the Avengers was like here's
new characters because you know they're
gonna team up at some point or they're
part of our universe it's like hey
here's Fox's movie to it like are they
making some kind of joint action going
all electrode Arianna's man i see that
reference the movie I've had it back in
that's what clever comedy is Alexi
morning learn it chew it up spit it out
then we wash your mouth with it
somewhere in there there's a sex show
that's right that's right somewhere in
there all right we're getting there now
we're getting the ball is you don't get
it we're getting there we're getting
there the ball is rolling the ball is
rolling this is really the only they're
both of the balls are old yeah yeah you
think about it yeah sorry it's a sex
joke I really hard we nailed it oh it